同学们，咱们上课。
嗯，又见面了啊，我是查理老师。
呃。
今天给大家讲点啥呢啊？呃最近呃大家也看到的短剧啊啊非常的火热。
呃，咱们的学生当中，目前目前在学习的同学呃，百分之六七十都是冲着短句来的啊，确实呃市场需求量很大。
但是最近有一个谣言啊，说什么特特朗普爱上在白宫做保洁的我。
说是赚了15000万美金啊，10亿人民币。
呃，已经辟谣了啊，这纯属扯淡。因为我们行内人看到这个呃消息，我们肯定是知道。
呃。
这是个假消息啊，因为这个数字有点扯淡，你除一除人数呀，是不是一个剧，多少人看每个人充多少钱，你算一算人数呀，他怎么可能是1个10亿的充值呢啊，这有点扯淡啊。
呃，但是这个市场非常火热啊，大家也愿意相信它火热，确实是真的啊。呃，所以说这节课呢讲一个大家最关心的一个话题，就是关于投稿啊。
因为这个投稿啊。
一直是咱们这个。
行业也好，还是咱们的课程也好，因为是一个重大话题。我教大家写剧本，那写完了咋投投给谁，咋样能能投中，这其实是。
呃呃，同学们最关心的一个问题啊，所以这节课关于投稿的方方面面，我们就。
嗯，跟大家说一下，包括同学们最近投稿经常出现的一些问题啊。
嗯，跟大家呃讲一下，咱们这个课是有合集的。同学们，如果你是在呃看到的片段，或者是只看到这个单节，你可以去找一找咱们这个课程合集啊，有系统的知识，甚至有呃拉片都在里面啊。
我今天看这个合集啊，发现咱们这个讲这个课啊。
已经5年半了，2020年的3月份。
开始讲这个课啊。
老学员可能知道我最初不是。
一个专门的老师，哈哈，我是一个。
这个编剧啊，一个影视从业人员，然后讲这个课是因为。
戴口罩的第一个月啊，因为当时风控风控。
没有事情做。
然后嘞。
当时想的就是呃因为我要带很多自己公司的编剧，我开影视公司嘛，自己公司有很多制片编剧和导演。
有的是新新人，有的是刚毕业的啊。
我当时就希望录一套这个教材哈给大家统一认知啊，当时是这么想的，内部资料啊。
后来是这个这套课录出来之后，大家觉得很有意思是吧？上传到一个网站上哎。
突然就火了啊。
啊，所以我们就走上了。
给大家讲课教大家讲故事这条路。
呃，后来确实也发现第一。
大家很需要。
不管是从业人员。
还是说爱好者，因为有很多同学。
他想进入这个行业。
没有机会，你就像我小时候，我们那小县生都没有艺考。
大家都不知道。
还可以去考一个这样的学校去去去从事影视行业。因为那时候影视行业也不火热嘛，对吧？
所以说有很多爱好者呢以前没有机会啊通过咱们的课程开始接触这个。所以说咱们在这个课程也是发展的越来越快啊。
我们简单统计了一下，你想到目前报过咱们的课。
也就是说正儿八经报过班学咱们课程的这个同学啊，已经超过2万个了，接近3万个同学是吧？
然后我们能统计到的，通过咱们的课程进入到这个行业的至少几千个创作者，还不算那些做自媒体的做短视频的。因为很多同学做通过咱们的课程学习，然后呢，目前在做新媒体行业也有很多。
单单是影视公司就有几千个。因为我现在因为我经常去各种影视公司开会，每去一个公司都能碰到咱们的学生啊，这是我非常开心的一件事情。然后出了多少作品，这个就没办法统计了啊。但是上个月我碰到一个同学啊，一个同学在网上跟我聊天，他是学的短剧课，他说他这一年啊学短剧课学了一年，卖了12个剧本。
我我我说你太厉害了是吧？偷摸卖了12个卷，就算一个两三万是吧？这一年也挣了好几十万了。
对于一个副业对吧？对于一个有班上的人来说还是非常好的一个收入啊。所以说这个我非常开心的就是呃。
这些事情支持我吧，支撑我啊，一直给大家讲课。当中确实有一段时间忙着去拍戏了啊，因为我确实不是专职的老师啊。
我虽然是这条赛道，网上讲课讲的最好的老师啊，但是呢呃我确实嗯之前没有拿出太多的时间来讲课，但是支持我的啊就是这些同学取得的成绩。哎，但是编剧这个课呀。
始终有一个难点问题，同学们。
其实就是投稿问题。
因为你像传统的电影电视剧。
他一年的产量就这么多。
而且普遍成本很高呀，你像平台定制的剧都是6000万起。
而且6000万是最低的。
那现在都是1亿多2亿多，对吧？电影就更不用说了，你看那些院线电影现在都拼成啥样。
你说那样的一个大制作。
来说。
很难给。
新人编剧机会。
让你主笔这个几乎不可能。
所以说咱们。
之前一直遇到这个难点问题。
导致有很多同学学会了，写的挺好。
但是呢每年中稿的就那么多。
因为咱们确实也会接一些订单啊同学。
我们会接一些长距的订单。
然后呢，让同学们去写。
但是。
消化量有限，好在后来出了什么呢？
这个。
消耗量非常的大啊，每天都开机几百部是吧？
而且短剧由于他的。
欠酬也比较低，两三万三四万这样子对新人非常友好。
老编剧也不愿意写呀，对吧？所以说这个大量的消耗短句啊，然后呃给了我们很多同学机会。咱们有很多同学借着短剧这股热潮啊，进入这个赛道，这是个非常好的事情啊。所以说呃咱们也尽力吧帮大家在解决投稿问题啊。因为之前长剧的时候。
我们能帮大家解决投稿问题，甚至是有服务。啥意思呢？就是甲方，比如说需要一个电影剧本，需要一个长剧剧本，我们帮他找好学生，比如说这个学生能写，或者这两三个学生一块写一个句，对吧？然后我们还提供对接，提供服务。因为长句的订单不多。
但是短剧现在由于订单非常的大，量非常的大啊。
我们是没有办法，同学们，他们为什么找咱们对接，你知道吧？咱说实话啊，你说那些甲方为什么找咱对接，帮他找人写剧本呢？实际其实让我帮他看，这个是个非常现实的问题啊，长句的时候我也愿意帮他看。为什么呢？因为他们除了付给这个学生片酬以外，也会付给我一个叫剧本顾问的费用。
一般是二三十万。
然后呢，我也愿意拿这个钱是吧？帮把这个剧本把万关怎么修改去，然后去参与这个剧本的创作。但是短剧一共就两三万的预算啊，他是不可能负我再去做这个顾问或者监制的费用的啊。呃，而且量也太大，你负我我也看不干，我也干不过来。
啊，所以说咱们现在呢就提供甲方跟咱们的同学直接对接啊，咱们同学的作品跟甲方甲方直接挑选，然后直接签合同。这样的话效率更高啊。这个这是跟大家讲一下，咱们的目前的一个投稿的一个状态啊，大家做的心里有数。然后呢有了短剧之后啊，咱们有更多的同学进入到这个行业啊，取得了很多的。
这个这个呃额外的收益吧，有些同学进到这个行业，有些同学拿着当副业，增加收入啊，这都是很好很好的事情啊，所以说咱们会继续的帮大家对接这些事情。好吧，当然了，讲课这几年啊，其实令我最深刻的印象最深刻的并不是说这个。
同学们的好评或者取得的成绩啊，其实我经常跟别人聊起来，这个这个开玩笑聊天的时候，令我印象最深刻的还是骂咱，你知道吧？不是骂咱啊，骂我。
呃，有的发私信，有的在评论，有的发弹幕骂啊。我也分析过啊，你看我是个老师啊，当老师就是爱爱总结，就爱总结他们为什么骂我一般分这么几类啊，有的是无差别嘛。
啊，无差别嘛，那就是。
愤青嘛，对吧？他管你是谁呢？就是露头他就骂这种就不谈啊。第一种就是。
无差别的嘛？还有一种呢是行业嘛。
就你一演艺圈的那你骂下酒流是吧？就是你们演艺圈的人还出来嘚瑟啊。
这就属于行业嘛。
还有什么呢？作品嘛。
对吧爱情公寓是毕竟有道德软肋，然后他也不管你这个跟你有没有关系，就是作品嘛啊还有赚钱嘛，这个是最多的。什么叫赚钱嘛啊，就是你这个老师在这讲课，你是不是要赚钱呀？
你是不是要卖克呀啊，割韭菜啊，骂你是吧？就是他不允许别人赚钱啊，这是个很普遍啊，网上有很多人就看到赚钱就骂，还有就是就骂你这个人，就骂查理，你这个人也有啊，这样这种一般是见过面的才会才会骂，就是熟悉你的人。
啊呃比如说之前有个。
有个学生跑过来。
要卖一个剧本啊，不知道他怎么找到我的，反正就是来找我说他有个剧本想要卖吧？然后嘞，我说那来都来了是吧？那我也接待一下吧，我说那你说给我听一下吧。
老师不好意思。
我不是不相信你啊。
我这个故事创意啊。
我只写给姜文导演一个人，因此只有他一个人能听我不是冒犯你啊，我不是瞧不起你啊。
我这个故事创意只有姜维能听。
我说那你来找我干嘛？他说你帮我约姜文啊，然后我就把他给拒绝了啊。这个然后他呃网上发文章了，就骂我啊，还有一次几个老先生也是哎呀，我也不知道他们这种老先生还反正也是神通广大啊，能找到我。
在哪办公？
一个老先生退休的老先生。
而且应该是退休之前还当点啥。
我为什么能判断他退休之前当点啥呢？为啥呢？因为他拿出来一个东西手写的啊，呃他不是来给我剧本找我说查老师。
你现在。
在这条赛道上这讲课网上讲编剧课这条赛道上。
是头部啊，是个网红。
我呢来给你当职业经理人，然后呢，咱俩一块干呃，利润三期开。
他只拿三。
我拿气，因为老先生已经退休了，像像像开发事业的第二春找到我了，相中我了。
然后他手写了一块。
商业计划吧，或者叫工作计划嘛，然后给我看，我一看我就觉得哎这老先生应该以前在提示那个工作，为啥呢？他写的商业这个商业计划。
其室内的味儿很浓，就是那种。
这个突出重点。
狠抓细节是吧？提高视野是吧？深入群众。
是吧全面的做好。
学生的。
这个创作工作思想工作，反正全世界动动就列举三点啊，全世界什么什么方面。我一看这个要30%，我也给。
玩具了啊，我送走他啊。
20分钟以内，我就看到了网上一篇骂我的文章，上千字啊，一看就是这老先生写的啊，因为这个口味啊和措辞一看就是他，因为刚写的回家的那个应该是回家的公交车上不用开车的话，看坐公交车上就给我骂了，写了洋洋散散一篇文章啊。
说我这个视野呀，这个眼界呀、格局呀，包括为人呀。
哎呀，就又给我骂了。所以说凡是这种针对具体人的啊，还是能看出来啊，是谁骂的比较令人惋惜啊。但是这个确实是你只要做公众行业，让别人知道你这个都是难免的啊。我其实对这种事情我倒不伤心啊。我分享出来给大家，只是给大家提供点素材。
乐呵乐呵，因为你做公众的事这个事情啊，一定有人骂你啊。很多同学说，哎呀行得正走得端，就没有人往骂我。你看我我就没有人骂我生活中从来没有人骂我。同学们，你如果只是在生活中啊，不是没有人骂你是你听不到呀，明白吗？
你生活中那些朋友，你的同事，你的朋友，你的邻居，你的同学，你的发小也有很多骂你的。
骂的更难听，只不过他们没有当面骂你，你听不到而已。
但是你如果是公众人物互联网这些人骂你，他也像没有过当着你边骂你，因为他匿名嘛。
不过是你能看到。所以说呃同学们如果以后做公众人物，不管是做编剧也好，还是做自媒体也好，自己做点事情也好，这个东西不用担心啊，不用担心，这说什么的都有。呃，之前还有一个同学也是在网上写了一篇。
旁文骂我啊，也是说误，反正写了很多骂我的话，但是有一个细节把它给暴露了。
因为他也是匿名嘛。
然后他说我这个人啊不学无术。
格格局很小，他举了个什么例子呢？
他说我经常躲在自己的办公室里。
玩连连看这个我跟你说，这个细节就暴露了，因为。
知道我在办公室干嘛的人不多的那这个我一下就有线索了呀。
然后我就基于这个线索果发现哦，果然是我认识的一个人，身边的一个人，我对他还挺好的。
对我也挺好。
完全看不出来他。
这么想骂我。
然后我就找到他谈了一次。
我详细了解，他又说哎，你看我说我们俩平常处的挺好的，我也没有对你不好，你也没有对我不好。为什么你会匿名写这么长一篇文章骂我呢？花这么多西子骂我呢？
后来他发现我也没有什么恶意啊，纯属于好奇。
纯属于。
采集素材。
然后他也自己也说，他说他可能有点嫉妒。
因为他也想。
走我这条路。
但是发现我很轻松就做到了，他就。
有点那个那个嫉妒和生气吧。当然我也原谅他了啊。
在这里我想跟大家说一下，澄清两点啊，第一，我并没有看起来这么轻松。同学们，我的备课也是很认真的。
而且我给大家讲课看起来好像想到这个说这个想到那个说那个，那是因为我20年的积累啊，同学们。
首先我做这个行业都快20年了，这是行业积累。第二，我我还是个读书人。
我读过很多很多的书，同学们，我虽然是一个非常强悍的理工男是吧？就是参加奥林匹克物理竞赛数学竞赛，然后高考数学满分，我是这种级别的理科男，我上海交大，但是我也读过很多很多的文学的书。所以我很认真的同学们，这是第一点啊，我并没有。
像我看起来这样好像是一个痞子老师不正经的老师啊，这是我想澄清的第一点，我给大家讲的课，我传授的知识是很严肃的。同学们，我在同学们，我在两所大学做导师，下个学期我就要出去另外一所大学，做一个学院的名誉院长了，我是一个正儿八经的老师啊。
I'm a teacher啊，这是我想澄清的第一点。我想澄清的第二点，同学们，我没有在办公室里成天玩连连卡。
我玩的是消消乐，00看是什么时代的东西啊？同学们，你们如果。
有我微信的话，你就会发现我永远排第一。
我是消消乐，全国百强，同学们。
不扯淡了啊。
开始讲课啊。
关于短剧投稿啊，每次讲之前都先说一个问题，关于短剧low不low的问题，总有人问这个问题啊，说哎呀老师短剧是不是太low了？老师，你以前是个正经老师，教我们写电影的，现在怎么教我们写短剧啊？老师我想进入的是影视行业，我想拍长安的励志，我想拍南京照相馆，你怎么让我们写短。
据啊跟大家说一下，关于这个low的事情啊。
嗯，我在课上其实讲过很多次了。
在这今天只讲一句话，所有能赚钱。
但是看起来low的东西都是。
既得利益者。
给他的枷锁，所有能赚钱，但是看起来有点low的事情，全是那些既得利益者定义的。
你给他点时间，他就不low了。
现在影视这条赛道的既得利益者是院线电影。
是平台的大剧。
那么短剧又很挣钱，又是新的东西，它必然给你道德枷锁，曾几何时，长剧也有道德枷锁呀。
曾几何时当演员也有道德枷锁呀，下酒流呀。
同学们，这这这个例子太多了，你看网上觉得开网店。
道德枷锁开网店把实体经济都摧毁了。哎呀，网店喽。
徒兄啊，我小时候开实体店野low，他竟然不上班，他竟然开店当个体户，他low死了。
曾几何是直播也low。
是吧。
做自媒体当网红也low。
现在大公司都在做布局自媒体，传统媒体这个人也在做自媒体，国家开发新闻发布会也在用直播。
懂吧？就每一个东西它如果既符责两符合两个条件，既赚钱又是新兴的那一定会有道德枷锁就扔过来了啊，这个非常非常正常，同学们。
你如果想赚钱。
你也是一个你如果不是个老钱，就是你没有权利，也没有矿是吧？家里没有老钱儿是吧？老资源让你挣钱，那你必须用到新的东西啊。
你现在说你你你新进入这个行业，你说我要拍这些电影，谁给你拍呀？
几个亿谁跟你玩啊？
对不对？所以说关于这个短剧投稿low不low的事情啊，每次都要说一遍。所以我们的结论啊。
短剧依然是小白进入这个行业最佳的途径，没什么好讨论的最佳途径。我们有数据啊，我们有这么多同学通过短剧进入这个行业来。我们今天啊先说一下最近我们收到很多很多同学的短剧投稿里面存在的一些共性的问题啊，共性的问题。先说几个误区。第一个误区。
观点表达很多同学写剧本，写故事之前先考虑比观点表达。
我们不提倡，特别是把观点表达当成自己的故事类型或者赛道。
这个我们就更不提示他了，对吧？很多同学说我这个故事我想表我想表达我反对校园霸凌对吧？就我想表达一个观点，反反对校校园霸凌当然是错的，反对校园霸凌是OK的，但这不是你的故事呀，你能明白我的意思吧？你先给我一个故事。
然后我们再来看你想表达什么观点，甚至你只要故事精彩了，它自然会有观点表达，你都不用自己。
总结观众就会帮你总结。所以说这是第一个误区。有很多同学写剧本啥故事没设计明白，观点一大堆，好吧，观点表达这不光是短句啊，长句我都不提倡你这样。
你觉得人家。
好东西，这个电影在写之前，人家就说哎呀，我就想呼吁男女平等。哎呀，你快拉倒吧。
先把故事讲明白吧。
塑造活灵活现的。
有血有肉的女性角色。
然后塑造。
不同的女性角色在这个度市当中生存的困境，以及目标，以及他们的坚强坚韧、正能量。
自然会引发大家对女性问题的关注，自然会引发广大女性的共情。自然会引发这个这个这个。
男性的反思。
因为他故事精彩，而不是去喊。
我们这个人怎么了？是吧？你去看一看好东西，从头到尾喊过这句话吗？
没有必要。
好吧。
观点表达。
不能统一的误区。
第二个误区。
以元素为主导也是错误的。比如说有个同学我说。
老师，我想写一个校园故事，请问应该怎么写？我说什么叫校园故事啊？
我什么时候教过你校园故事啊？
校园是你这个故事当中的一个元素。
而且是个环境元素，校园里可不可以有人之间的情感啊情感故事。
校园里可不可以有一个人很有励志，很有目标，励志故事校园里可不可以有一个人遇鬼了？
经故事校园里可不可以有有一有有人死了。
悬疑故事、凶杀故事，对不对？
校园是个元素。
千万不要以此为你构思的切入点。
或者是说哎呀，我想写一个校园故事，校园故事有个什么注意事项啊？问我这种问题。
完全错误。
当然了，有些同学说，那甲方这么说的呀，那甲方也未必每个人都懂呀。那甲方如果说他要个校园故事，那你就要问清楚。那基于这个元素，他要个什么风格嘛？
对不对？你校园的青春爱情跟校园的凶杀，那肯定是完全两波受重呀。
同样是所谓的校园。
对不对？所以说一定要把这个元素给我搞清楚。
好吧。
不要以元素为主导。
那我们同学说，从我们写故事的角度，我们构思一个故事，我们的主导是什么呢？期待就我这个故事能引发观众什么样的期待。
才决定了我这个故事。
咋写或者是我这个故事是个啥类型。
你看咱们课上我们只讲这种所谓的类型，因为你这样确定类型，你才知道咋写呀。比如说我是我我这个故事是个校园故事，那你先写啥再写啥，对吧？这肯定不对的呀。
我们如果是说我这个故事是如何引发观众期待的？
那我就知道咋写了。
那如何引发观众的期待呢？我们现在只给出五类。
分别是。
人的成长故事。
是吧人的成长的故事，然后人对目标的一个追寻。
追求追寻这么一个故事。然后呢，我们对困境的一个摆脱，摆脱困境一种故事。
对吧我们的梦幻愿望实现了的故事。然后呢，我们这个这个悬疑故事一共就这5种，引发观众期待呀。
就这5种方式，要么来。
我明明是这么好的一个人，对吧？困在这样一个环境里面，哈利波特我们希不希望他成长？
这个人的成长，这个人飞上枝头当凤凰，或者是个人摆脱这个环境，或者这个人这么聪明，我真的希望他能成才，三傻大闹宝莱坞是吧？
人物成长或者这个人他是个假的，他是个假县长。
他是个假学生，逃学威龙是吧？他是个假老师摇滚校园是吧？人物成长目标追寻很多盗墓笔记是吧？鬼吹灯这个这个抢银行的是吧？或者是公路片，我们有个目标，我们想去那个地方，我们想找到谁？我们想得到什么？我们想偷到什么。
对吧我们想报仇，我们有个目标。
那我们观众自然有期待呀，他能行吗？
就你这几个能行吗？或者啊那么远啊，能找到？
是吧菊次郎的夏天目标追寻一下，我们观众产生的期，你看我为什么说是期待我们写故事一定要同咱们反复讲啊，第音型原理我们写故事为了啥，对吧？我们这个故事为啥能挣钱，为啥能让观众看完，不就是揪着他的期待不放嘛？让他老对我们有期待，生活里面也是这样呀。
你一直让别人对你有期待，那你就牛逼呀，牛逼的人就是别人对他有期待呀，能不能实现再说，他反正你对我有期待，故事也是这样呀，不是某个元素，或者不是某个观点吸引他呀。
是吧我们从来不会说哎，我们去电影院看一个电影吧。
这个电影。
讲那个那个讲了一个观点，我很认同是吗？他这个观点我很认可，那不是这样的。
你真想搞观点，那你演讲去啊，太得演讲不就完了吗？
对吧第二种目标就行。第三种，摆脱困境，遭灾了，遭难了。
是吧当然这个灾难可以是天灾，2012，也可以是个人的家庭的灾难。海边的曼乔斯特对不对？就是有难了，有困难了。
困在这儿了。
是吧海神号我困在这儿了，困境嘛，摆脱困境也是我们的期待呀。这有困难了。我们看看他能不能走出来，怎么走出来。然后第四种梦幻愿望这个也是非常多的，特别在短剧和网剧当中非常非常多。啥叫梦幻愿望？
有一种说法说，电影是是人类的梦，共同的梦是吧？
故事是梦呃，有很多这种说法，为啥呢？是因为在很多时候影视故事是我们实现不了的事情。
那不就跟做梦似的嘛？那你想想看做梦你梦里面有时候不就挺挺牛逼吗？白日梦我突然发财了，夏洛特烦恼突然重生了，我突然发财了。西红市首富愿望梦幻嘛，重生呀，金手指是吧？哎呀，漫画里的谁突然出来帮我了，奇魂是吧？
悬疑悬疑。
拉起来。
曾经被大家认为是唯一的，有很多人写故事，觉得让不让观众期待看下一集，那就是悬疑5分之1啊，5分之1都不到。实际上这种类型没有前四种。
数量多啊，没有遣丝数量多。但是有很多同学在没有学之前，总以为我要让观众对我一直有期待，那就是让他看不懂，那就让他有疑问，谁杀的。
到底男的女的？
那可到哪儿去了？
不对呀，我明明看到他藏就是瘸疑，这才是你构思故事的类型。所以说所有的同学以后投稿跟我探讨故事，探讨类型，不要跟我说，老师，为想写一个校园故事。
那校园还他妈有可能外星人来了呢，所以说这是第一个问题啊，很多同学啊在故事类型上有问题。第二，创作规范。
为什么一定要人物小传和故事梗概？
是吧为什么一定要人物小传和故事梗概？因为剧本是一个工作手册。同学们，你要拉起所有人对这个故事的认知，他才能看进去吧。很多同学那人物小传啊。
她是一个刚从这个失去孩子中走出来的女性，坚强的女性啊，结束了。
他多高。
好不好看，喜欢穿啥样衣服啊？
是吧语言行为有什么特点呢？
是不是受过啥样的教育啊，社会阶层都不写。但犯这种问题，同学们很多同学觉得啊呀，那就是我大意了错。
说明你脑子里面没有画面，且不愿意分享好的编剧。第一，脑子里面画面是全的，我要塑造一个人物，这个人物他妈走路什么姿势我都有，必须色香味俱全，是吧？那这好的人物你在脑编剧里面脑子里面都有的呀。
明白吗？这是第一第二呢，我很愿意分享出来，我是个编剧，我要让导演知道他是个什么人物吧。我要让这个这个道具和服装精确的知道我的人物需要准备什么东西吧。我希望演员精确的表达我这个人物吧。
所以我作为编剧，我当然想把这些东西都写出来。
你如果人物小传都给我马虎，那肯定是不对的。
好吧。
然后再就是故事梗概。
很多同学这个故事梗概写不好啊，故事梗概写不好。比如说有些同学写了很多前提。比如说这个人呃本来是什么样的一个人，遭遇了些什么样的事儿。小时候他爹怎么怎么对他不好，读书的时候又被人欺负。然后呢，工作以后吧，遇到了一个什么什么样的人。然后有一天那个人让他去倒茶。然后呢，在这个倒茶途中，他听到了一个什么。
然后不小心听到这个事情之后呢，人家就决定要弄死他。弄死他之后，他发现自己重生了，一切都重新开始结束了。
我看的是重生故事呀，同学们。
重生以后发生了什么，才是我们观众要看的。
你这个故事梗概里面全给我写前提。
很多同学有这样的问题啊，或者是。
故事梗概写很多。
呃，还有很多同学在故事梗概当中写，全写的是可能性。
比如说我这个故事会探讨一个中年男性跟如何平衡家庭与事业之间的关系。
如何在理想和现实之间是吧？夹缝中生存，就写的全是也虚的。
也是一些同学写的。
在这里今天统一给大家规定一下啊，你如果要写一些故事梗概，至少要包含哪些内容啊，至少要包含哪些内容给大家规定一下来。
首先，环境、时工环境设定都包括在这里面啊，有些同学也有强设定，比如说金手指啥的，重生啥的啊，环境首先要包含环境，然后呢包含人物。
我的主角是谁？
主要对手是谁是吧？包含人物。然后呢，这个主角遇到的情境或者叫情况，我们一般叫情境，你可以理解为情况。他遇到了什么样的一个特殊情况，咋的了，对吧？让他遇到这个特殊情况之后，他有一个什么样的决定，或者是说他准备怎么干。
一个行动。
对吧然后采取这个行动必然会有阻力障碍，甚至有反派，对吧？那就带来对抗。然后呢，在故事的当中一定有一次大的转折，但是最终总要有解决方案吧。我怎么那样解决的这个问题。然后我的结局是什么，回到了哪里？
所以说一个故事梗概至少一个包含这些内容吧。
在一个什么样的环境里，什么样的设定下是吧？什么样的时空环境，然后一个什么样的人。
对吧。
他遇到了一个什么样的？
棘手的情况或者紧急的情况或者特别的情况。
或者有意思的情况。
然后呢，他准备怎么干呀。
那干这个事儿必然是。
不是一帆风顺的吧。
对吧遇到哪些问题呀？
然后遇到这些问题的过程中当中会有一个大的转折。但是最终我还是要解决这些问题啊，解决方案。然后解决完了之后，故事的落脚点，或者是这时候你可以谈一谈哎，有什么样的意义。
结局。那这时候很多同学就会觉得哎呀，那这个转折具体咋转呢？来回到这里引发观众期待，你看这就有用了。同学如果问我说老师校园故事咋转折，我那怎官怎回答不了。但是你如果按照我们的故事类型问我就好转了。
人物成长类的故事。
叫转折四个字叫做回自己所有人物成长类的故事，转折都是做回自己。不信你看人物成长类故事。我们刚才举了什么摇滚校园一个。
摇滚歌手去当老师，没什么文化。
那这显然是一个人物成长故事。我们说假身份一律属于人物成长类型的故事，因为他不适应这个环境，他一定要成长嘛，他得学着做老师嘛。所以他的故事的前半段，他为了当好这个生物老师不断的学习，不断的假装。
的故事后半段呢。
教音乐吧。
我教大家唱歌吧，做回自己，功夫熊猫也是呀。
我在前半段我做一个很胖的厨子，我需要拼命的练功，我拼命的像我我的那那个五个师兄一样，成为一个大侠神龙大侠。
故事后半段呢做回自己，我用我爹教我的做面条的技术来打败我的敌人，做为自己。
好吧，故事的大转折。当然了，你去这只是理念啊，你根据你的具体的故事行为，目标追寻型的呢故事的转折是。
方法错了或者叫换个方法，有时候甚至是换个目标。也就是说你之前追求的这个东西啊，你的方法是错的。
我们比如说我们说公路片，很多都是这样，菊次郎夏天，我开始的目标是什么？找妈妈菊次郎跟跟郑楠踏上征程市找他亲妈呀。通过一个明信片上面有地址找他亲妈呀。
但是在故事中间发现找到这没有用呀，你妈也不会要你喽，因为他找他妈，他以他本来以为自己是孤儿，但后来发现他妈有记性过来，他要去找他妈，那找妈是要找爱呀。
但是发现你妈根本不要你，对吧？那你这个找妈就错了嘛，那后半段又是什么？找爱嘛？有人爱你不就行了吗？你干嘛非得找你妈嘛，对不对？换个方法或者接换个目标，就目标追体型。
困境摆脱困境，大转折是直面困境。因为所有的困境电影，比如说侏罗纪公园。
恐怖片儿逃出绝命岛是吧？游于游戏，反正就种困境类的故事，海参号都是是吧？至于这个 triangle那个恐怖游轮对吧？
前半段都是淘宝。
所有的前半段都是我如何躲避这个困境，消解这个困境，逃出这个困境，后半段都是跟这个困境磕死磕吧，你逃不掉的。
跟他干嘛。
是吧复业复生液是吧，干嘛跟这个困境干嘛。
大转折殖面困境。
梦幻愿望呢。
梦幻妖呢？
所有的梦幻愿望呢？
所有的梦幻用啊，比如说金手指，比如说。
同伤。
穿越在故事的前半段都是享受红利。
我们以夏洛特烦恼为例，来回到初中，前半段当歌星套的那个秋雅是吧？挣大钱，社会地位什么都上去。所以在故事的前半段实现梦幻以后，故事的前半段全是。
嗨起来爽起来，我们叫享受红利。
是吧然后故事后半段那显然要回归现实。
一般说什么？珍惜眼前人。
是吧。
活着才最好，真实才最好。这些梦幻。
如泡影。
所以他后半天晚上回去找马冬梅是吧？然后找他妈，发现他妈也跟着走了。
什么也都离他而去了，朋友也都背叛他。
有要钱干哈呀，要这么多钱，要那么多地位干哈呀，身体也垮了，什么都没了，是吧？回归现实悬疑。
谜题凶杀案。
这种故事。
故事的中间的大转折是啥呢？我们说大转折一般在故事的正中间啊正中间啊。
反正是啥？
解读谜面。
谜面儿。
啥意思？
悬疑类的故事就像猜谜语啊。我本来有个谜面。
比如说上来就告诉你连环凶杀案。
那我的故事前半段肯定是寻找谜题，寻找答案呀，连环这个连环凶杀案到底是谁干的？我要寻找这个答案。但是在故事大转折的时候。
我们不找谜题了，我们重新解读谜面，就是这到底是连环凶山。
这该不是是连锁自杀吧。
对吧。
不像连环凶杀案呀。
为什么之前一直找不到指纹或者找不到统一的指纹？
前面这个人。
有后面这个人的指纹，后面这个人有后再后面这个人的指纹，我操。
这是一个连锁自杀互助小组啊，你杀我他杀他他他他他接力棒啊，对吧？那你看重新解读谜面，来，故事就迎迎来一个新的转折。你去看那些破案的片子，全这样，同学们。
你去看阿加莎。
每个都这样。
凡是上来就咣老头死了，然后所有人来争议一查啊，这个啊老头死了。
然后到故事中间的时候，我没死对吧？我就看你们怎么争，或者是。
没有人杀他。
他是自杀。
没有凶手，找了半天，凶手，没有凶手，重新解读谜面。好吧，就是跟大家说一下，关于故事梗概啊，一定要规范。很多同学写的太不规范了啊。来关于设定，由于很多同学在写短句的时候喜欢写强设定啊，写强设定一般会出现这么几个问题，同学们常见的问题。
第一，创新很多同学盲目追求创新。总以为说老师很多同学跟我交给我稿子啊，第一句话就老师，我这个设定或者我这个题材你肯定从来没见过。
同学们，凡是说出这种话的啊，我就一般就心里就咯噔一下就不妙了。为啥？首先没有这种故事，好故事不可能从来没有人写过。
太阳底下没有新鲜事儿，同学们，第二，他说出这句话，说明他使劲儿的方向使反了。
他就是要写一个你没见过，那就完了，就好像炒菜一样。如果有人告诉你。
我今天这道菜我管饱你一辈子都没吃过，那你心里肯定咯噔一下。
西红柿炒鞋垫儿。
肯定没吃过呀，那能吃吗？
是不是那是没吃过呀？
所以说。
创新啊是很多同学犯的第一个问题，总想写一个，哎呀，我这个创新我让你没见过，对吧？我这个穿越，但是呢我跟他们的穿越可不一样，他们是单穿双穿，我是三穿，他们是前后穿，我是左右穿，我是先穿过去，然后再交换灵魂，然后我就我就是跟他们一样。
别整这一套。
好吧，过度创新过度复杂。
都是我们非常不提倡的，为啥呢？因为创新设定啊本质上是要牺牲观众的信任感的。
你为了增加新鲜感，失去了信任感，对吧？但它是个平衡，新鲜感我们也要信任感我们也要啊，所以说不用过度创新，不用过度复杂。
第二呢呃还有呢就是这个逻辑问题啊逻辑问题，很多同学的这个设定啊没有逻辑啊，没有逻辑。这个这个还有的呢呃你像最近有个同学给我讲讲给我讲了一个就是穿越以后同时具备了超能力。
我说为什么？
你为什么要这么写？他说那我都穿越了，我还不能再有点超能力啊，但是为什么呢？
对不对？你穿越到古代就就还得有超能力，这就是重叠啊，逻辑都都都。
都没有啊，都都都不行啊。还有同学呢呃不考虑性价比的问题。
性价比低啊，性价比低什么意思呢？就是比如说来我现在这个故事有一个很强的设定，那必然带来观众的期待啊。我举个例子，比如说我这个人是个外星人，外星来的。
对吧外星来的，那外星来的那我就要想后面的剧情就必须与他他能呼应上这个外星啊。最后你只给我兑现了啊，他就是性格有点怪，他对地球上很多事儿他不太理解，所以他性格有点怪。我们说这个性价比就很低。
那你就设定它是一个。
从小不出门的人不就完了吗？
对不对？所以他性格有点怪啊，这就是个性价比的问题。好吧，就关于设定啊，同学们要注意。
然后视角很多同学啊呃呃不太理解这个视角说我们这个故事吧，到底是一个什么视角或者是主角，主视角在哪里？视角模糊的问题。
同学们记住11一句话啊，你的故事的主要视角。
是跟着观众的情绪走的。
也就是说，观众担心谁。
视角就在先身上，我给你举个例子啊，有个同学前几天交了一个稿子，说老师我写了一个。
女性视角的剧本，因为他是个女孩子嘛，因为我之前说过嘛，我说如果是第一个剧本啊，男生写男性视角，女生写女性视角这个这个编剧是个女孩子，他说我写了一个女性视角剧本，我看完了，我说我没看出你这是女性视角呀，他写了一个啥故事，你知道吧？他写了一个男生突然就不去剧透他的创意了啊，反正这个男生就突然。
遇到了一个很大的问题，非常荒诞，非常棘手的问题。
然后呢，也不能告诉别人。
对吧然后呢也上班也慢慢的捂不住了，最后呢，到底是偷偷生下来还是怎么怎么办？怎么解决这个问题，怎么怎么调查，到底是哪来的，以及最后如何通过这件事情反思以前自己不尊重女性也好，还是什么也好，反正就是。
这个男生也改变了自己成长。我说我哪看出来你这个是个女性视角。他说你看我女主角，我说你看我通篇看老是这个男孩子的戏啊，他的成长，他的困境，他的目标观众都是跟着这个男性情绪走的，说不对呀，他说我还有个女主角呢，我说你这个女主角在那干嘛？
他说我这个女主角是这一切的始作俑者。我说你别管我使不是，我我不管你始不始作俑者，我说他在这个戏里面在干什么？
观察这叫视角啊，同学们啊。
暗中观察，看起来哎听起来好像是视角是吧？观察嘛。
但是观众的感受是跟着这个男生走的呀，因为这个男生遇到问题了。
他能调动观众的情绪，这就是个明确的一个视角模糊的问题，明白吗？谁能调动观众的情绪。
你视角在谁身上？
观众跟着谁走，所以这个视角一定要做好。
好吧。
来还有一个突出的问题，现状现状走吧。
很多同学啊这个一上来我们都要交代主角的现状，这个大家知道的，因为现状交代完了，我们为什么要主重交代主角现状？同学们，因为现状交代完了，我们要让主角走出现状呀。
对不对？这样才有力量嘛，主角要走出现状，走出舒适区啊，或者是这个这个改变他的现状呀。我们希望他改变现状呀。
但是现状很多同学交代不清楚嘛，就几场戏，因为现状我们需要短。
短而精准短促精准是我们的现状的要求啊，很多同学写不好，啰里八嗦，写的也不动人，也没交代明白，信息信息量很少。在这里呢我们统一强调一下啊，现状我们。
做到4点。
记忆。
共情。
期待。
隐患。
也就是说上来前几场戏交代我们主角，你你可以理解交代主角的现状，其实就把主角给交代出来了。
所以说非常非常重要，下来能不能摁住观众？
有时候就是第一集的内容。
所以说我们这里这里提这四点要求，你交代一个主角现状，我们把这个主角介绍给观众的时候，这四个点给我做到。第一，我们的这个人的记忆点是什么？
他凭什么让我们记住他了？
他有什么特点？它有什么技能。
技能也是啊，同学们，这人是个神医，他妈这也是记忆点呀。
对吧我们对他的记忆点是什么？
或者他卓而不群的地方在什么？
对吧或者是他这个环境格格不入的东西是什么？他的价值观跟别人不一样的是什么？
对不对？他是这个酒馆里站着喝酒，唯一穿长衫的人。你看鲁迅先生一句话就把积点拿出来了，他站着喝酒，说不定他没钱，他穿长衫，说明他体面。
他是站着喝酒里面唯一穿长衫的人，一句话，这个鸡点多牛逼啊。
细点。
然后共情点，我们为什么爱他，我们为什么跟他站在一起呀？他有什么可爱的地方？
或者他有什么跟我们很相同的地方，这他到底跟我们哪一点共通呢？共情点，然后呢，期待点也得有呀。
期待是吧？
将来有可能怎么破局暗示给观众了。
给这个期待的同时，隐患也要给了，对吧？他不知道的一件事情是什么。
或者是。
有一个人已经盯上他了。
或者是他要干这件事情，他以为他要悄悄悄悄行动，但是这个秘密已经被人知道了。
有人要出卖他了，隐患也给到。好吧，在这里咱们今天这节课统一要求一下，以后所有交上来的现状，我就查这四个方面要有。
不要不规范。还有个问题啊，情绪拉情绪啊，很多同学一个重大的问题，情绪不会拉。
很多同学觉得哎呀这个短距情绪一定要拉满啊，我就要使劲打。
哇。
我给你举个例子啊，就昨天有个同学叫过来。
其实也不是他一个人啊，很多人来短剧是不是很多低开？
主角低开上来很惨嘛？很惨。然后这个主角混的不好，那后面有了金手指之后，或者是后面遇到什么转机之后爽起来嘛，是吧？传统套路很多同学上来就写这个主角很惨。
然后呢。
他以为他把情绪拉满了，昨天这个同学写了，就这个这个。
女孩女主角，我说你这个女主角上来，那肯定得先低开嘛，他写了三场戏，第一场戏跟他父母。
他妈这个女孩的妈打电话给他骂她。
20万什么时候打过来？
你弟弟要结婚啦，一看就是伏地魔嘛，对吧？他在他妈妈眼里就是个赚钱的工具，是？展现他妈妈不爱他，就想让他给他钱给钱给那个。
给弟弟，这是第一场戏。第二场戏呢到了公司之后。
领导欺负他是吧？领导。
倒个咖啡都不会倒啊，咖啡泼到他脸上，你这个猪。
让他同视一眼，你这在那这啊这个嘴啊眼也挤挤他。
是吧。
然后回到家以后。
筐。
高利贷把门给踹翻了，进来几个高利贷的人咔咔扇他耳光，什么时候还钱是吧？哐哐他写了这么三场戏。
同学们说，这个情绪拉满了吗？
拉的好像也不少，对吧？拉的挺满的。
但是有个问题啊有两个问题。第一。
现实生活中真有这样的人吗？
太不真实了。
对吧。
第二我就问这个同学，我说你看啊他在公司这场戏领导拿咖啡泼他，同事呢也骂他，瞧不起他，所有人都欺负他。
是不是他自己做人有问题啊？
你想想看嘛。
如果一个人到哪里都讨人喜爱，所有人都想扇他一个耳光，甚至拿滚烫的咖啡泼他。所有人。
是不是他他做人有问题呀？
明白我意思吧？同学们。
你这不叫拉满情绪啊，你根本把这个人物给毁了呀。
非常的不真实，而且不讨人喜欢。我们甚至有点讨厌它。
我在这个公司，我狗不也想踹他一脚。
对吧。
所以我就跟这个同学说，我说你看啊调动观众的情绪不是这么玩的。
不是这么玩的。
对吧我说要基于真实把观众的情绪拉满。
比如说。
同样这三场戏。
家庭。
公司高利贷、家庭职场高利贷嘛，就家庭职场黑社会嘛，对吧？这三场戏来家庭的戏来。
你妈打电话给你。
实际是关心，也就是表面关心你。
对吧。
然后呢，他不是辱骂你，他是道德绑架。
他说哎，你看你当年。
考学的时候。
对吧你非要学设计，设计的学费比别的学费贵2000。
我们都供你念了。
对吧现在你。
你弟要结婚。
道德绑架你。
我说这对于一个妈来说，亲妈来说，道德绑架你足够扎心了吧，而且比直接骂你养你这个女儿有啥用，要力量要大的。
对吧你妈假装关心你，实际句句道德绑架你。
软刀子让你自己说出好，我弟弟的彩礼，我来想办法，而不是20万必须打到我账上，对吧？这不是这不是你亲妈呀，这是王妈呀，这是对吧？不真实，我说你看妈这场戏可以这么处理。
对吧然后。
到公司也是不要所有人的。
公司没好人啊。
对不对？公司没好人吗？
我说来。
公司也要有人支持你的吧。
比如说。
同事是吧？有比他比你更来得更晚的女实习生吧。
老板顶头上司可以是一个大混蛋。
是吧然后又没有。
才能又暴躁，甚至还有点好色是吧？然后呢。
对新来的女实习生下手。然后呢，你假装过去倒茶，实际是为了帮这个女孩子解围，结果劈头盖脸到你头上了。那你为什么会去帮这个新来的女女实习生结尾啊？
因为你也走过这一步呀，你也被他欺负过呀。
所以你才能共情人家。
然后你看看你这样在被骂，观众是不是就同情你了？
你是帮比更比你更年轻的女孩子解围了呀。
所以你才假装进去倒咖啡嘛，所以他才会把咖啡给泼了呀。
对不对？你这样记你有没有显示别人找你他在工作上故意为难你，但实际上还是有人感激你的呀。比如说那个。
新来的那个大学刚毕业的女孩子，对吧？擦着眼泪走了，但是她回过头来。
他是感激你的呀。
明白吗？不就又又有真实又有力量。
然后回到。
假。
来，还是黑社会来B债。
对吧。
我们说。
踹门扇耳光，他妈的一下跨在你头上。我们说这种西征有这样的黑社会吗？对不对？也不真实，黑社会他也是份工作，他也是想把这自己的钱要回去。
对吧你实际上反映的是我们这个主角走投无路，而不是这个黑社会像个跳梁小丑。
所以你看我们也写信，来，我工作了一天，在工单位也不顺心，爹妈也不理解，我回来了之后。
对吧因为生活很窘迫，对吧？
他写饿了一天嘛，我说那你就不要饿了一天了呀，还是弄点东西吃吧。比如说翻出来最后一包泡面。
很喜欢的一个口味。我虽然生活这么不好，但是我很喜欢这个口味的面，我自己煮一碗面，我很开心的，我还打了个蛋在里面。
但是确实是我最后一点口粮了。
刚煮好。
要债的来。
你眼中的你最后肚子很饿，最后的一碗温暖的面还没下口。
人家进来了。
人家来很凶的坐在这个沙发上告诉你。
是吧你钱得还了。
啊，我们已经够客气了，然后这个面在人家眼里，人家尝了尝，人家那个大哥拿起来就随口操什么玩意儿躺扔一边。
对吧然后呢用来抬源头了。今天生活当中唯一的小确幸，唯一的小幸福。
在他们眼里成为了烟灰缸。
不用啪扣你头上啊。
你想想看这碗面扣你头上。
还是说人家尝了一口，这他妈什么玩意儿，你赶紧还钱啊，然后痰烟灰了，哪个有力的啊？同学们。
不是谁他妈闲着没事，老把方方面面扣别人头上了。
所以说这个拉情绪啊，同学们真实是第一位的。
让观众痛。
不是啪啪啪扇耳光，然后脚踩在你脸上，然后在那还钱，没有这样的人啊，对不对？所以说还是要真实啊，情绪要真实。
明白吗？
这就是关于这个投稿啊。
我很多同学教的这稿子啊，中稿率没中上，或者是你交的稿子老也不中中稿率低。你自己想想看你有没有犯这些问题。
好吧。
然后关于最近的征稿啊，这里跟大家说一下。
蒸稿两种形式。
所有报过咱们。
学习班的同学。
联系你的助教老师啊，征稿有两种形式，有一些甲方看的是1500字梗概加人物加前十及剧本，好吧，这是一种格式。
1500字的梗盖，1500字的梗盖拿写啊？
人物啊以及前十集剧本前十集剧本一定要注意啊，情绪给我拉满。很多同学就说，哎呀，老师他们说我的剧本节奏慢，他们说我的剧本不生动。我跟你说，就是情绪没拉满。
情绪拉的不对，明白吗？好，这是一种。然后呢，还有。
完稿剧本。
也有一些甲方要完稿剧本啊，这种情况你就不要专门去给这个甲方写。因为确实写完稿需要的时间比较长啊，还是那句话，之前有很多同学手里攒了很多玩稿了，攒了很多玩稿剧本了，在需要有完稿剧本的甲方的时候可以交。
好吧，然后格式问题对接甲方的问题，助教老师都会帮助大家。
另外呢，咱们最近啊为了。
帮助大家为了帮助更多的同学创作，试试谁，看看自己能不能写啊。呃，由于咱们之前帮大家对接剧本啊，这个同学们理解一下，咱们帮大家对接剧本呃，要找助教老师，因为全是咱们学习班的同学。那至于很多同学没报班。
是吧没参与咱们的系统学习，也想试一试。
这个短剧投稿。
这样啊。
所有想要。
测试一下自己能不能写或者是应该怎么写的同学，咱们给大家开一个平台。也就是说在接下来我会给大家上一些直播课，直播课的内容是什么呢？帮大家批改故事创意。
但是这个故事创意需要按照格式来写。
这个故事创意我们要求300字。
300字以内啊，因为不能太长，我们会在直播课当中帮大家批改故事创意。300字以内。然后300字以内写什么内容呢？依然是环境人物、环境人物、情境、行动、行动线啊遭遇的阻力包括对手。然后呢，当中大的转折是什么？以及最后怎么解决的这个问题。
解决了这个问题之后，所有的人和事儿的归属是什么？
把这个给我写明白。
300字以内。
好吧。
嗯，这个批改是免费的。
我们接下来这段时间会拿出。
几个月时间吧啊，这个夏天和秋天，因为现在剧本收的量比较大，我们其实想鼓励更多的同学进入这条赛道。所以说如果同学们有故事创意，或者是希望知道这个故事创意能不能写以及怎么写想让我给你看啊嗯可以抓住这个机会啊，300字以内。
嗯，交给助教老师啊，助教老师的联系方式啊，这个会留给大家。然后同学们呃进到学习小组里面。
这个这个是免费的，好吧，但是呢我们会呃不能保证每一个都及时给大家批，呃，只能是在直播当中啊一次批个几十个。这样好吧，所以同学们不管是参与哪种考稿啊，如果是已经是咱们学习班的那你直接参加跟甲方的对接，甲方有什么建议，甲方有什么。
问题啊直接沟通呃，谈妥了，价格也是直接沟通。当然可以在签合同呀，在版权啊，在立项这些方面可以获得我们助教老师的支持和帮助。这个没有问题。好吧，因为大家都有自己的呃专属的助教老师和班主任，好吧，如果没有参加咱们学习班的同学，想要试一试自己的故事创意行不行，或者让我帮你指导一下怎么写。
你在哪里看到这个课啊，看一看评论区，看一看这个这个屏幕上啊，找到那个咱们助教的联系方式啊，先把这个交给他，然后看看行不行。
呃，还是希望所有的同学啊。
呃，都能讲好故事啊。
剧本啊。
说破大天是讲故事啊，不是表达观点，也不是卖弄技巧。
明白吧？不是给别人上课。
我们是要把故事讲好，要动人，要调动他们的情绪，懂吧？好吧，所以所有同学都体会这一点，不管是长剧、短剧还是电影，逻辑都是一样的，让观众爱看，让观众有期待。希望同学们都能努力创作。咱们今天就讲到这吧，下课。